le destin de l'univers repose sur vos
épaules maintenant quoi que vous fassiez n'appuyez pas
dessus mais parce que cela déclenchera la
bombe immédiatement et nous serons tous morts
maintenant répétez ce que je viens de dire oh non
c'est le bouton il tuera tout le monde
réessayez kunkka mm-hmm uh-huh
No Showtime a-holes
[Music]
est-ce que quelqu'un a une bande là-bas Je
veux mettre une bande par-dessus que ce
drôle
personne n'a de bande pas une seule personne
n'a hé tu as une bombe atomique dedans  ton
sac si quelqu'un va c'est un très
mauvais signe
si je touche quelqu'un je peux ressentir ses
sentiments tu ressens ouais ouais je suppose ouais
je ressens un amour désintéressé général pour
quelqu'un pas sexuel non non je ne sais pas
te voir voler tout le monde ton plus
sombre  mec secret allez je pense que
tu exagères un peu
tu dois être tellement gêné
toi